[Music]
[Music]
hey folks
welcome to the dark horse podcast live
stream
number 51 dr heather hines sitting to my
right
i am a dude yes here we are number 51.
we are here
and we have a lot to talk about because
2020 marches
on things are afoot so
i believe that we are going to uh start
by talking about some uh social media
shenanigans uh
to put it rather more lightly than is
actually the case and then
move on to talking a little bit about
the nature of mass movements
all right the nature of mass movements
good well i'm looking forward to that
but yes we should start
with what has happened in the last week
it seems like a month but you know
that's the nature of uh
time travel at the uh the period
approaching the election
here's what happened for those of you
who have not been paying attention
what happened was i was involved in a
private discussion in which somebody
posted a
facebook link that i was supposed to go
look at and i clicked on the link
and i got an amazing message is that
could you show the message oh
this is awkward we're waiting to show
you the message here's the message
it says your account has been disabled
you can't use facebook because your
account or activity on it
didn't follow our community standards
we have already reviewed this decision
and it can't be reversed
etc etc so i saw this i was completely
shocked
now those of you who are not facebook
friends of mine
i might need to give you a little bit of
orientation i used to be
not a heavy user of facebook but a
regular user of facebook
and then after the evergreen meltdown
facebook became a very toxic environment
and i effectively walked away from it
moving most of my social media presence
over to twitter where things were more
manageable and more hospitable believe
it or not
um so i barely post there and i was
shocked to see this
um this warning here that says that my
account has been permanently disabled
because
as far as i knew i hadn't posted
anything on it recently and i believe
i might have logged in logged on in
october but
my last logon in which i did anything
might have been even
september so what the heck triggered
this well of course we don't know
because it's facebook and
they do not feel obligated to tell us
anything about what rules
uh mean how we might have violated them
and there's no mechanism
to uh to appeal the decision so
uh i was suitably shocked and confused
and i
posted a tweet zach could you show the
tweet it says i have been evicted from
facebook no explanation no appeal
i have downloaded quote my information
end quote and see
nothing that explains it we are governed
now in private by entities that make
their own rules and are answerable to no
process
disaster is inevitable we are living it
and this we're governed now in private
thing that you write here is in
uh reference to the same thing that you
talked about
i believe in our last live stream in
which you were talking about basically
government is that which governs yes
that's exactly what i'm referring to
government is that which governs and so
it is uh there is no shame to the
founders that they did not anticipate
social media
and therefore did not protect the rights
that they knew were necessary
in order for democracy to function in
the context of social media because
there would have been no way
to write those rules so what we are now
stuck with
they were remarkably prophetic but they
could not predict the specificity
of the future nor especially so many
many years out right i mean you know the
rate of change is impossible
as it is and they couldn't have
predicted the rate of change much less
what was happening
as the rate of change itself accelerated
the the
these people had never seen a train they
had never seen a chainsaw
um they would have uh known of at least
hot air balloons that's about uh the
extent of the tech
is that right yeah the razzle dazzle
that would have been available to them
and imagining
what was needed but there would have
been no way to anticipate this and you
know
to see the degree of the problem think
about if somebody had told
you in 2000
about twitter that they had told you
there was a wildly popular service in
which people were limited to a tiny
number of characters and they barked
into the ether
and others listened and rebroadcast
these things you wouldn't have known
what they were talking about
and i might have begun looking for a new
planet right um
yes uh elon get on it oh no no
no no i don't want him in charge because
he'll take us to mars and there's
nothing to do there right
right okay well i would agree with that
but in any case there's no way we could
expect them
to write rules that would have protected
us and the thing that you know the
problem that we have to deal with
is we are told uh
by an ever-present chorus of people who
respond when one complains about an
arbitrary decision
like this that well these are private
corporations and you're using their
service and you're getting it for free
and they're entitled to do what they
want so
tough and the answer is actually no
this is now an essential artery of our
democracy
to the extent that it is now
bottlenecked by people who are up to
this
uh sort of political shenanigans and i
will get to why i believe it is
political in a second here
but to the extent that it is
bottlenecked by those people one of two
things
has to happen either we have to be
provided an alternative where our rights
are protected or our rights have to be
protected in the context of these
private platforms so that democracy can
do what is necessary
the entire reason that we have the first
amendment is because
the exchange of ideas the free exchange
of ideas
was understood correctly by the founders
to be essential to the functioning of
the democracy
right they knew they had to protect good
ideas bad ideas vile ideas they had to
protect the whole
landscape from governmental interference
in order that we could govern ourselves
well that the
good ideas that sound wrong at first
could rise to the top
and you know gain resonance and they
were
as i said quite right that this was
necessary
but they couldn't possibly understand
where those ideas were going to be
exchanged in
the 21st century so we are now stuck in
this predicament where the rights are
not protected where it is clear that we
are
actually uh involved in the discussions
that affect governance and we are being
governed by private concerns that are
not
protected are they from which we are not
protected just an asterisk for perhaps a
later conversation i wonder if some of
the problem
that we have when trying to have this
conversation with people when they when
they respond with
it's a private corporation they can do
what they want
is the the naming that calling them
social media suggests that is in fact
media and of course freedom of the press
suggests exactly that something like the
new york times has editorial control and
they can publish or refuse to publish
whomever they want and that is
part of what freedom of the press
guarantees
and that calling these these platforms
social media suggests that they are like
that
except that they effectively have
monopolies right and
and in fact there is a provision i'm uh
is it 2 230 i've forgotten the number
but
there's a question about whether or not
these platforms are publishers or not
and in effect the
platforms are taking the position that
they are publishers
where that protects them uh and that
they are not publishers with respect to
responsibilities so they're they're
gaining the better
yeah they get the best of both worlds
and it leaves us with a bad predicament
but
if i can complete the story here if you
look at this tweet if you're
watching this on youtube you'll see it
has quite a large number
of likes now this is on twitter
on twitter yes my uh my pointing out to
my twitter followers that i had been
banned from facebook without explanation
and no opportunity for appeal
caught people's attention because uh
well as you can see in the replies to
that tweet people regard me
as a very uh sober and responsible voice
and they wanted to know what i might
have done on facebook that could have
triggered this the answer is
nothing um and so anyway it spread
like let me just you it's not even that
everything that you would have been
doing on facebook i mean you've already
said this but it's not even that
everything that you had been doing on
facebook was completely defensible and
well within
you know everyone's understanding even
of like the overton window that
these the social media platforms are for
some reason patrolling the borders of
um but you literally had said nothing
right there was there was literally
nothing that prompted this so far as we
could tell because you literally aren't
active on this platform and i'll say i
don't even have a facebook account and
never have so i can't even
view what's going on there but um like
literally you had done nothing
and usually that is actually
metaphorically you'd done nothing here
just there was nothing that you had done
on facebook that prompted this well
right i mean
you know unless they decided to go back
into the history there's nothing i did
in the period here where i got banned
they could possibly explain it because i
wasn't doing anything so
um i think the the you know i referred
in my uh tweet
suggesting that people come visit us on
on dark horse today
that we were going to pull back the
silicone curtain and
silicon curtain and the silicon curtain
here reveals
i think that there is a politically
motivated core within facebook that has
the power to ban
people and frankly i think if i had been
active on facebook recently it probably
would have found something they've set
you know community standards that are so
arbitrary and vague
that they can find something but in this
case it was like well i didn't do
anything that could justify this
because i wasn't active and so we'll ban
him anyway and what's he going to do
about it there's not even a
link where you can click for an appeal
they tell me they've already reviewed it
okay now already reviewed it
has a very clear connotation it suggests
that a human being
looked at this and decided that whatever
the complaint about me was was
valid and that's why i have no right to
an appeal because the appeal had
effectively already been filed on my
behalf and i had failed to
compel them that i was a decent citizen
all the steps that can happen have
already happened you're done
yeah um totally orwellian all right
so as this tweet that is uh
i guess now on the screen um was
uh was gaining likes and being
circulated at some point a
representative
from facebook popped in in the replies
zac can you show the next
so liz shepard who
uh goes by liz bourgeois
on twitter of all the tone deaf things
to say
says your account was mistakenly flagged
by our system for identifying imposter
accounts
we've restored it and are sorry for the
mistake
now i find this fascinating
because this clearly suggests that this
was an automated phenomenon
which then seems to call into question
whatever review
they claim took place that meant i
wasn't entitled to any sort of an appeal
she says it was flagged by our system
for identifying apostrophe accounts
now that i think is nonsense because my
account is a very long-standing account
i have a large number of facebook
friends they are
coherent in the sense that many of them
stem from places that they that are
geographical places
you know places i've worked evergreen
and the like so the account does not
look like an imposter account nor was it
behaving like an imposter account
because it was largely dormant
so clearly something is up
well how am i ever going to figure out
what might be the cause of this
well i don't know let's see who liz
shepard is can you go to the next
screenshot zach
liz shepherd facebook comms formerly at
the democrats and speaker pelosi
my god this person is directly connected
to
top-level dnc democrats
could it be that my unruly behavior
suggesting that the
duopoly is a corrupt entity and
must be addressed in order that we
properly govern ourselves could it be
that i caused offense and they called in
people inside of facebook in order to uh
to punish me or to provide a warning to
others who
might um be uppity in this particular
way
certainly seems likely but the the
account is even strange
take a look at it now i must say this is
a screen grab from today
liz shepard has a lot more followers
today
than she did when she popped into the
replies to tell me that they had made a
mistake over at facebook
she had fewer than a thousand followers
and she was following more than 800
people
so that's not a good ratio there are
enough people who follow back that
you know to follow 800 people and have
less than a thousand followers i mean
she's
a very uh light user of twitter or not
very
interesting to people and yet here she
is verified so
somehow it would appear that twitter
which hasn't verified you
you're a notable person how many twitter
followers do you have me um
what 120 120 000 followers you've
actually had people
uh pretend to be you am i correct uh yes
unfortunately
yes you've had people actually trying to
actually had imposter accounts show up
actually had impostor accounts show up
and twitter refuses to verify
you i should say when i got verified
there was a
process for requesting that they
establish who you were
and you know if they decided you were
notable whatever that means
they would do it and then when you did
the same thing
they had changed the process and
basically they said
that they were no longer verifying
people because it had become
a hallmark of like a sanction from
twitter
um but this is nonsense they're well
that's i mean that's that's a rabbit
hole but uh it's not they didn't say
they're no longer verifying people
they're saying they they want to do it
by
application anymore and by demonstrating
that you have a public presence
they basically acknowledge that they're
going to they're going to give blue
check marks to whoever they feel like it
and you can't request it
and you don't know when it'll come if
it'll come they turned it into exactly
the thing they claimed it they didn't
want it to be which is a sanction from
twitter
you can't apply for it exactly they will
hand it down at the point that they
uh they like you and apparently they
don't like you yeah i'm very likable
i guess not i mean i find you like thank
you but uh but twitter
twitter does not agree so in any case
it's bourgeois though quite likable
yeah lou shepard here she is quite
likable
um and you know a proud uh
dnc democrat connected to speaker pelosi
so
that does suggest a possible
explanation for what is taking place so
i tweeted back
can you go to the next screenshot and i
said my first indication of a problem
was this message saying facebook had
already reviewed the suspension and the
decision can't be reversed my tweet
about it clearly got your attention
meaning you liz shepherd but i have four
hundred thousand twitter followers
what protects regular people from such
quote mistakes
liz nothing nothing protects regular
people from such mistakes
especially when the original message
suggests that everything has already
happened that could possibly happen
and that there is no way that you could
possibly get
get another review because reviews
already happened yep
now uh i will say the it's
deeply anti-democratic now twitter
doesn't claim to be democratic
this person who now works for facebook
is apparently part of the democratic
machine one would hope
that she lived by democratic principles
or would choose to work for an
organization that does
this is not democratic well yes of
course
the elite democrats of the dnc
are famously not democratic in fact
uh some viewers will remember that
howard dean's
joke before he disappeared from
the uh the race um
in what year would that have been i
don't remember
in any case actually you should uh check
out eric's um
opening essay on his most recent portal
with with
uh douglas murray he talks about the
dean
scream episode the thing that ended
dean's
candidacy but but howard dean used to
joke
that he was from the democratic wing of
the democratic party that was his line
it was hilarious because all of those of
us
who were liberal democrats
understood that there was this machine
inside the party that wasn't interested
in democracy and was basically taking
advantage of us
and dean's renegade candidacy
gave us hope for a while the way more
recently you know bernie sanders
campaign
did and tulsi gabbard um so
all right you have the uh yeah it was
halfway through bush too it was 2004.
2004. yep all right so
liz shepherd has not responded and
explained anything more about the
mistake
um i think we've gotten all of the
information we're going to get and
probably we're not going to find out
anything more but it is certainly
interesting that they
uh that liz is sanctioned by twitter
an establishment dnc democrat proud of
such
on her profile now these connections
though
are many i don't think we have any idea
how many of these people are inside of
facebook
and twitter and google occasionally one
of these things
reaches the attention of the press so
we've seen several other examples that
could you put up the next screenshot
so here we have nick pasilio who is
at communications at twitter that means
uh
he is basically at twitter comms whereas
liz shepard is at
facebook coms coms having something to
do with decision-making power over what
is and is not tolerated on the platform
and he is a former kamala harris press
secretary
isn't that interesting all right next
screenshot zach
all right now we have uh
can you read his name i can't see it um
it's carlos monreal um
carlos monge is uh he was
at twitter he has now moved on to
biden's transition team
seems a little premature to me but
nonetheless he's moved on to biden's
transition team um so
in any case there are these connections
we don't know how many of them there are
and we don't know what the interaction
between
these partisan folks in
uh in our governmental structure and
these private platforms is but
in some sense what we have is a
new version of the revolving door
right so the traditional revolving door
as it is used to describe
governmental corrupt corruption involves
people who take a who step out of
industry
and into government for some number of
years and then return to industry that
would be the classic pattern
and of course it functions as some kind
of a legal bribing mechanism because the
person knowing that they've come
from an industry knows what the industry
wants knowing that they will return
there they do the industry's bidding
and the point is no fingerprints another
way this can work
is industry can approach somebody in
government
persuade them hey you know when you come
out why don't you look us up see if
there's a job
that we might have for you yep it's
another
mechanism but then this version with
twitter and facebook and presumably
google
has a different spin to it right it
works in a different
direction that in effect instead of
going into government to do industries
bidding these are people from
a partisan faction of government who go
into
industry right to do the parties bidding
and so it's a different revolving door a
fundamentally different revolving door
but it's no less influence pedaling well
that's just the thing
so if we can step back and of course
this is a heck of a week to be
discussing influence pedaling
um but what we've got is um
a party which is not supposed to have a
product
right parties are supposed to represent
people like me
lifetime democrat you as well lifetime
democrat we are the democratic party but
the democratic party is
run by the dnc which is as i've been
saying throughout the
period of unity and influence peddling
operation
pure and simple now that influence
peddling operation
has to acquire power for which it needs
votes
and then what it does with that power is
it peddles it
right so to the extent that voters stop
electing the democratic party it has
nothing to monetize it can't sell its
influence and so it must maintain that
influence it must win voters
how do you do that well you've got to
control the conversation because if
people were to understand what's
actually driving policy
they would throw the bums out so how do
you control the discussion
well the discussion is taking place on
twitter on facebook
on instagram who knows where else so the
point is the revolving door
now has to be in the places where the
bounds of polite conversation are
set in a private context so there is no
first amendment protection
and we are left with the results and
what does it look like
well frankly it looks like what twitter
did with the hunter biden story
right twitter actually shut down
the account of the new york post a 200
year old
newspaper and made it impossible to
share in a normal sense the article
in which the obvious influence peddling
going on in the biden family
was made plain there's no justification
for this
obviously the voters have a right to
understand that that one of the major
party candidates
has a son who was peddling his influence
when he was vice president and they are
entitled to extrapolate that that might
characterize a biden administration
too and this is of course deeply
connected to recent history
because it was um you know the ukrainian
connection and the allegation
of influence peddling that caused the
president to yes i believe
he abused his power trying to get
biden's son investigated in ukraine
which triggered an impeachment uh so
you know this is the most important
business of the nation
here you have real revelations that
appear to be robust on the basis of
evidence right evidence from hunter
biden's own
computer and we
we are being told that that information
is so suspect that even though published
in a major american paper
it cannot be shared we're not even
allowed to see it and decide whether it
makes sense to us so we are now being
uh we are being infantilized and lied to
and having our right to decide actually
i do want to discuss that
overridden by you know it's not the
nanny states the nanny corporations
so uh i mean the whole thing is
absolutely frightening
and you know i have to
point out that the motivation for the
uh unity 2020 plan
was that we were faced with essentially
an influence peddling operation on the
democratic side
and a different version
of abuse of power on the republican side
and that
it was the system that caused
this sort of breakdown that left people
frozen out of
governmental power which has made them
frustrated and angry and is causing them
to lash out in the streets and
essentially we have to confront the
mechanism that generates this failure
or it's going to take the republic apart
and you know we're seeing it we're
seeing it all laid bare
we're looking at the corruption we're
understanding how it functions
we're seeing that it actually is you
know it is affecting the way we are able
to
collectively think by basically deciding
not to pass certain messages
i mean remember the unity 2020 twitter
account
was suspended for registering
uh phony accounts in order to boost the
hashtag
and it didn't register phones it did not
do if we didn't do it so
suspended for an infraction which it did
not engage in and it remains suspended
and it is true even this week that if
you attempt to dm
somebody a link to our website in which
we discuss
governmental corruption it's a very odd
behavior
you try to dm somebody and on your side
it looks like you've succeeded in doing
it
on their side it's hidden right it's a
very
bizarre nefarious way of controlling
what
thoughts i mean you know think about it
this way so you said it's not the nanny
state it's nanny corporations and i'm
not there's something important here and
it's not
quite right because censorship you know
we do censor what
children are allowed to experience right
and so if if we can if we could take the
connotation of nanny out of it like you
know where
who who gets in loco parentis who who
gets to take on the status of sort of
parenting
the populace to some degree you know we
as
as liberals really truly believe
that given especially the global nature
of some things like
like social media like a lot of
technology we need regulation
that actually does protect the populace
from
some of the things that that cannot be
regulated by
individuals or cities or state level
right state as opposed to
nation or more but
censorship is something that has always
been a part of um
of human life and here we have a sort of
imprimatur of uh from
from what from the corporations that
are actually allowing us to speak with
one another
uh that is deciding when and what
we are allowed to hear and with whom
we're allowed to speak
whereas in the past what the state
was protecting us from with regard to
corporations was often
corporations basically doing sort of you
know
psyops on on us and
um advertising such that we would
not engage our best our best interests
and become our best selves so
there's some like there's some mess here
um that it's not quite so cl it's not
it's not clean i don't think you meant
to suggest that it was clean that it's
moved from sort of nanny state to nanny
corporation
that there's that there's censorship
that there's still
attempt to create motivations
in people that um serve the corporation
rather than
the person and maybe part of what you're
seeing and saying here
is that now we have corporations working
on behalf of particular political
parties
who want to change the motivations of
people even when that is not in their
best interests and isn't only in the
interest of
uh in this case the dnc well i think
there there are two things there yes
it is not the people you know the nanny
the reference
nanny is about an adult who is empowered
to tell you no
presumably to protect you from your own
worst instincts as a child
right and so being infantilized by a
government that wants to protect us
against our own instincts
is bad enough when it actually happens
now the term nanny state is often used
to dismiss
regulation that exactly that is about
preventing
real harm that can't be prevented in
other ways but
but it is also true that we see
overreach but the thing is as americans
the
values encoded in the first amendment
whether the first amendment should
in some way be extended to or something
else should come to protect us online i
mean and i would remind you
twitter facebook google these are
private concerns
but they are on public roads i mean the
internet
started as darpanet right this was our
governmental structure generating a
mechanism
that then created an opportunity for
these private concerns but it's not a
simple matter of hey they're private
they can do what they want because
effectively we don't have a public
access to this internet that we built
right so it's one of these things where
there's at the very least a gray area as
it is with research where
um the public funds the research and the
uh the product of it is private
and as it has i mean just more more a
closer analogy would be say the
telephone companies right you know the
i don't i don't remember the history
well enough to to even
replay it briefly but um you know the
government went in and broke up
um um and made a bunch of baby bells
because there was a monopoly and
you know in fact the airwaves are ours
the airwaves are ours
and the you know the in the case of of
telephone it's not airwaves but similar
things have happened with regard to
networks um yeah this is true
but at a deeper level i would say we
americans
have almost uniquely protected speech
on the basis that speech itself is not
understood to be harmful right or at the
very least
that the harm that can come from speech
itself that is to say there's lots of
bad speech but it is a symptom of
something else that is harmful
but to the extent that speech might even
be harmful it is understood
that the greater harm is done by
empowering something to decide what can
be said
which is exactly what is happening here
and so it actually
strikes me that there's an analogy
between this question and something that
we discuss
in our book about um the fact that in
our ancestral environment
a bad smell was not itself
typically harmful i mean in fact almost
never right um
that is to say you smell something bad
like a rotting fish and the fact that
you've smelled it doesn't hurt you but
it does tell you don't eat that
right now in this case warning itself is
not dangerous it's telling you
it's it's advising you as to how to
modify your behavior going forward
as opposed to right so in in this case
you've got
you know you can have hilarion speech
right it's not the speech that hurts you
it's the hitlerianism that generates the
speech so hearing the speech
actually allows you to deduce that
there's something dangerous there
whereas blocking the speeches if the
speech is doing the harm
then leaves open a it makes certain
things taboo which makes them attractive
and b it means nobody's really in a good
position to know what is being
thought and how commonly okay i'm not
sure
i don't think i love this analogy
because i thought what we talk about in
the book
is that modernity has brought with us
smells that themselves are
are dangerous like solvents um solvents
uh what toluene or something
is toluene yeah yeah i think right so
um this is a novel circumstance for
which we have no
evolutionary history and in general um
the response to recoil in response to a
bad smell and to not go towards it and
to not eat it and all of this
has been sufficient up until at least
until the industrial revolution i think
more or less and it's not sufficient
anymore and it's impossible to tell
unless you happen to be familiar with
the particular thing that you were
smelling
based on smelling something novel and
reprehensible to your nose whether or
not the actual smelling of it is doing
you harm
i don't i think that some of what is
going on with regard to for instance the
actual free speech debate
is that people on the authoritarian left
are making exactly this claim about
speech
that now speech itself is going to harm
you and i
i think this is this is completely wrong
and therefore i don't like this analogy
no it is wrong
but this is the point is you know what
we need to have a discussion about that
because to the extent that speech is now
being equated with violence
that is something that we have to
determine right if it is if something
about speech has changed we need to have
a discussion about what it is and what
that means about the regulatory
environment and assuming
that nothing has changed that speech is
still speech and violence is still
violence
then the answer is actually where is
speech taking place
that's where we need to protect it
especially if there is no alternative
so this it all creates a pretty
interesting
puzzle and um the derangement of our
ability to think is obviously downstream
of these corrupt entities like the dnc
influencing these private concerns which
are beyond the reach
of of constitutional protections
which are the places where we have all
gathered to figure out what's what and
we can't figure out what's what because
if you think what's what
involves you know the articles of unity
uh web page you can't send it over dm
to somebody so you know if you think
about the way memory works
you know memory at a biological level
involves you
detecting that things have happened or
that you think they've happened
and then when those things are
reinforced because you return to them
they become inscribed in your memory in
a deeper way so that they last so you
can't remember what you had for
breakfast last thursday because you
haven't
thought about it right so it that memory
has vanished other memories
get built in they get wired in so you
can access them for life because you
keep returning to them
and so in some sense you've got the
nanny corporation deciding
there's certain thoughts that we would
rather you not remember there
it's like proactive memory holding you
know what we don't really want you to
remember
is that hunter biden actually sold
access to his father
and you know was employed by this
corporation and that this was connected
to an impeachment
of a sitting president so add to this
the um derangement of memory that comes
with
how pretty much all of us now use the
internet where even those who try to
those of us who try to be scrupulous and
clear off our virtual desktops and close
down our tabs and all of this
will will at some point usually pretty
reliably
have open a million tabs right and so
you just keep
running into the same thing where you
like i left it open because i thought
maybe an oh right
and you know every time you run into
this it comes it jumps back into memory
you recall something maybe a little bit
less than you did last time about the
eight connections that you thought you
might want to make
but it makes it less likely that you can
actually put
together a coherent map of your universe
and i'm reminded um
actually i think this also might be
something that
we heard about in the book i'm reminded
of one of my favorite
short pieces by um by borges
called funes the memorials in which he
reports on someone
maybe at some point i'll i'll just read
it it's very short um
he reports on a character who cannot
forget anything
and this seems to be the way forward the
way that you end up just becoming
replete with knowledge and of course of
course no
because the way that we make sense of
our universe is to take in
as many things as we possibly can and
then to do the analysis and the editing
and the calling and to be left with the
certain this is you know this is
actually how develop some of development
works too right let's like
apoptosis the selective this programmed
cell death
where and we start with webbing between
our fingers and then we you know we lose
the material that we don't need
this and this happens with neuronal
growth as well as well right we have
many more neurons and neuronal
connections in utero
and in very early childhood than than we
then have as adults and it's not
that we're getting dumber it's not that
we're getting stupid it's that
you over build and then you and then you
trim
so memory memory works best when you can
you can fill but then you have the time
and the space
for the analysis for the thought for the
reflection
and you don't have to keep being
reminded of the things that you
kind of thought you were already going
to get rid of or you
thought ah maybe maybe this maybe that
let me put it in some bucket and be
reminded of it once a month
as opposed to oh my god i got 80 tabs
open
let me see what's on them well actually
um
if you think back uh the movie version
of
men in black right is there a non-movie
version of men in black
uh yeah it's a it's a comic oh um
the neuralizer the device that allows
these uh governmental
ufo dudes to cause you to forget what
you've just seen because lots of people
in this
movie world are seeing aliens all the
time and the government is you know
erasing these memories
it's almost like these uh media these uh
social media platforms
are using a neuralizer who are they
using it for oh they're using it for
their friends
you know high up in these governmental
parties where you know yeah
presumably these platforms love the
access that they have and they don't
understand
that the corruption of the government
structure is actually endangering the
republic that they're depending on
and you know it's all a frightening
catastrophe
but yes the magic of understanding how
to think
involves editing down it's a sculpting
process and
the insidious thing here is this is not
an
individual free to engage in thinking
about things and then
editing away the ones that weren't that
valuable the dead ends and all of that
this is some external force that doesn't
have to explain to you what their goal
was or why they thought something wasn't
for you to think about it's editing your
memories down right it well
yes you need at least two things to
learn to to be able to think
uh carefully and to learn how to be in
possession of a mind that can do so
you need to be free to find whatever
information you go looking for
and this is you know this is one of the
reasons
that uh some people uh lament the loss
of actual like library stacks right that
actually walking around
a physical library where things have
been more or less put
into a spot so that you you went looking
for one book and you end up finding 10
others that are
a little bit related but not quite which
is harder to do when you're doing
say a google scholar search or you know
web of science search looking for
scientific literature for instance um
but then you also need
the the silence basically the mental
silence and the ability to stop at the
gates any more stuff from coming in and
impinging on your ability to
consider what all it is that you have
now taken in and what it means
and uh we we are losing we are losing
both of these
do you have more here or shall we well i
would just say in
closing ultimately the
um the message that i want people to
derive
is that the influence peddling itself is
destroying the republic the mechanisms
through which it functions and preserves
itself
are ever-changing but i believe it is
the case that until we figure out how to
deal with the influence peddling problem
and the fact that it has left the
american public
as a side light to issues of policy
we're going to face a system that gets
worse and not better
and to the extent that twitter and
facebook and google
don't want us discussing the influence
peddling by the people that they assure
us we have to vote for
they are the problem and we're going to
have to confront them
so i think that's where we are
can't damn a river on your private
property um
meaning that private property is not the
end-all and be-all
of uh of rights and i i unless
unless you own the the land that the
river runs through all the way out to
the ocean
in which case you might be able to but
so long as the river goes on to other
people's land
you're not allowed to affect um that
that which is not yours with regard to
damming water and we are all having deep
effects on
each other so these ideas of this is
mine and i can do with it what i want
is often not the case because right
there are deep implications yeah all
right
all right um so i
last week we did a deep dive into rod
drear's new book live not by lives
live not by lies which is uh named for
the solzhenitsyn essay which i read an
excerpt from in the previous episode in
episode 49.
and um after that
um i was thinking a bit about this book
which i've had on my bed stand for a
while eric hoffer's the true believer
thoughts on the nature of mass movements
and i've dipped into it here and there
um and
um and i think it
really has a number of things to teach
us about our current moment
and in a way there's there's some hope
to be
to be had from it so this book was
written in 1951 which means
it has um the issue is all
older tomes do as all older texts do
just as we were talking about with
regard to the constitution the framers
of the constitution
um they could not have accurately
predicted what had not yet happened and
so the examples are inherently from
that time uh in this book and and before
um and so we i think we might
extrapolate a little bit from
some of his thoughts but let me just say
first so basically i want to talk a
little bit about what enables mass
movements
who participates what are the tools by
which they work where do the fanatics
come from
and specifically then how can creativity
provide resistance to their appeal and
what do honorable leaders look like
like um so um
this eric hoffer um just reading from
the back
um was self who lived from 1902 to 1983
was self-educated and lived the life of
a drifter through the 1930s
after pearl harbor he worked as a
longshoreman in san francisco for 25
years
and he was awarded the presidential
medal of freedom in 1983 and died later
that year
and specifically the true believer which
is the first of his books
um which i guess if it's published in
1951 the first of his books was
published when he was 49 years old
um became a bestseller when president
eisenhower cited it during one of the
earliest televised press conferences
so that's what this book is i can't
imagine
a current politician um reading or
citing
a book a book like this and would would
that they could
actually okay so i'm going to read a few
short excerpts as we proceed here let's
see
from the very beginning the preface this
book deals with some
this book deals with some peculiarities
common to all mass movements be they
religious movements social revolutions
or nationalist movements
it does not maintain that all movements
are identical but that they share
certain essential characteristics which
give them a family likeness
all mass movements generate in their
adherence a readiness to die and a
proclivity for united action
all of them irrespective of the doctrine
they preach on the program they project
breed fanaticism enthusiasm fervent hope
hatred and intolerance all of them are
capable of releasing a powerful flow of
activity in certain departments of life
all of them demand blind faith and
single-hearted allegiance
all movements however different in doc
however different in doctrine and
aspiration
draw their early adherence from the same
types of humanity they all appeal to the
same types of mind
though there are obvious differences
between the fanatical christian the
fanatical [ __ ] the fanatical
nationalists the fanatical communists
and the fanatical nazi
it is yet true that the fanta fanaticism
which animates them may be viewed and
treated as one
the same is true of the force which
drives them onto expansion and world
dominion
there was a certain uniformity in all
types of dedication of faith
of pursuit of power of unity and of
self-sacrifice
there are vast differences in the
contents of holy causes and doctrines
but a certain uniformity in the factors
which make them effective
he who like pascal blaise pascal finds
precise reasons for the effectiveness of
christian doctrine
has also found the reasons for the
effectiveness of communist nazi and
nationalist doctrine
however different the holy causes people
die for they perhaps die basically for
the same thing
this book concerns itself chiefly with
the active revivalist phase of mass
movements
this phase is dominated by the true
believer the man of fanatical faith he
was ready to sacrifice his life for a
holy cause
and an attempt is made to trace his
genesis and outline his nature
as an aid in this effort uses made of a
working hypothesis
starting out from the fact the
frustrated predominant among the early
adherents of all mass movements that
they usually join of their own accord
it is assumed one that frustration of
itself
without any proselytizing prompting from
the outside can generate most of the
peculiar characteristics of the true
believer
and two that an effective technique of
conversion consists basically in the
inculcation
and fixation of proclivities and
responses indigenous to the frustrated
mind
so this this strikes me
there are a number of other places that
we want to go here but
his his core hypothesis in this book is
that
actually finding a group of people who
are frustrated
is is is sufficient and i think he is
actually arguing that it's um
that is maybe not necessary but if you
have it it is sufficient so it is akin
to necessary and sufficient
to creating a mess a mass movement if
you if you then know
what to do with it um and i would say
that there's something
there's something to be teased out here
from the election four years ago in the
united states the 2016 election
there were the vast majority of people
on the left
saw trump seeming to use exactly the
frustration
of a vast majority of people on the
right as a unifying agent
that he was saying things like drain the
swamp and
uh make america great again and we're
going gonna bring jobs back
and we're gonna stop the flow of people
who are taking your jobs and you know he
was finding the ways that people were
frustrated
and um those on the left could look at
his rallies
and his rhetoric and the seeming
lockstep approval
by his rallying base and see in it the
seeds of these other kinds of mass
movements fascism for instance and this
was the thing that we started to hear
from from the left right like he he is
gonna bring in fascism
this became in turn the and i
we have said many many times that we we
don't see that we don't think that trump
was trying to be fascist nor was um nor
is likely to bring in fascism but he was
using
some of these kinds of of techniques
of um of the most effective leaders of
mass movements
specifically by cueing in on the
frustration of
um of a of his base this then became in
turn the rallying cry
of the mass movement that rose up quote
in resistance right
um what we now see many on the left
everyone from
you know the woke to the mainstream
democrats who were largely playing ftse
with the woke
are using fear-mongering
and hatred and mass delusion by claiming
that fear-mongering and hatred and mass
delusion is what trump is doing
and therefore that's what that's what
people on the left must do as well
so it's a mass movement to um the claim
is to defend against
what seemed to be maybe a mass movement
and i would argue actually what was go
what was going on with trump was was not
that it
it wasn't what it appeared to amelia on
the left but what has a what has
what has risen up and what's what
happened long before
the 2016 election actually um was they
were looking for an excuse they the
the hard left the far left right we're
looking for
an excuse to create a mass movement and
could could they find
huge numbers of frustrated people of
course
of course they could you have something
to add here well
i mean i i think you're pointing to
something
interesting which is that the
frustration that usually causes a mass
movement
has caused two mass movements yeah and
the reason i mean maybe that's more
common than we know
but that essentially what you've got is
i don't even want to call it an unstable
equilibrium because
i think i drew a diagram on one of our
podcasts before
that basically had a zone of stability a
little trough in which the ball could
reside but if it went
too far in one direction or the other it
went over the side
right yes and in some sense
maybe that's not the right model here
maybe the right model here is that
you've got a trough that holds the ball
and then something causes it to be a
peak and it causes a slide into two
different things but basically what
you've got i would argue the
bottom thing is a very novel system that
is making people sick
and a very corrupt governmental
structure that is freezing them out of
the solution-making
yep right so they are left outside that
is almost
literally going to cause frustration of
every kind the sense that
one cannot do enough that is right to
get ahead
right that thing will cause people to
look for the explanation of
what it is that's blocking their
well-being
and that means they are susceptible to
snake oil salesmen who want to tell them
that you know what is causing your
frustration is
rampant racism right really didn't we
just elect a black president twice i
mean
you know is it rampant racism yes it's
rampant racism that's the reason
you know or on the other side i guess it
would be
you know it's uh governmental
incompetence
and uh immigrants or whatever it is
that's you know
taking the well-being that is due you
and driving it somewhere else
and the point is really if we were
paying attention and understood deeply
we would recognize that actually there
is something
that is taking well-being and it's rent
seekers and they own the governmental
structure
and they are dealing with us as an
inconvenient periodic electoral hazard
that has to be dealt with
um but that you you want to jump start
the economy right what you need to do is
get the governmental structure to stop
functioning in this partisan way and
bipartisan in this case i just mean
working for people who can buy access
and against everyone else
yes and how do you how do you do it how
do you bring the frustrated together
uh there are a number of unifying uh
unifying techniques and by
unifying i don't mean anything lovely or
wonderful but
in in hoffer's explanation um you know
how is it that you bring the frustrated
together
um what can unify them well hatred
obviously right so uh for instance
here from hoffer again hatred is the
most accessible and comprehensive of
all unifying agents it pulls and whirls
the individual away from his own self
makes him oblivious of his wheel and
future frees him of jealousies and
self-seeking
he becomes an anonymous particle
quivering with a craving to fuse
and coalesce with his like into one
flaming mass
mass mass movements can rise and spread
without belief in a god
but never without belief in a devil
usually the strength of a mass movement
is proportionate to the vividness and
tangibility of its devil
when hitler was asked whether he thought
the jew must be destroyed he answered
no we should have then to invent him it
is essential to have a tangible enemy
not merely an abstract one
f a voigt tells of a japanese mission
that arrived in berlin in 1932
to study the national socialist movement
voigt asked a member of the mission what
he thought of the movement he replied
it is magnificent i wish we could have
something like it in japan only we can't
because we haven't got any jews
it is perhaps true that the insight and
shrewdness of the men who know how to
set a mass movement in motion
or how to keep one going manifest
themselves as much in knowing how to
pick a worthy enemy
as in knowing what doctrine to embrace
and what program to adopt
the theoreticians of the kremlin hardly
waited for the guns of the second world
war to cool before they picked the
democratic west
and particularly america as the chosen
enemy it is doubtful whether any gesture
of goodwill or any concession from our
side will reduce the volume and venom of
vilification against us emanating from
the kremlin remember this is 1951.
one of shanghai sheck's most serious
shortcomings was his failure to find an
appropriate new devil once the japanese
enemy vanished from the scene at the end
of the war
the ambitious but simple-minded general
was perhaps too conceited to realize
that it was not he
but the japanese devil who generated the
enthusiasm
the unity and the readiness for
self-sacrifice of the chinese masses
so this this line mass movements can
rise and spread without belief in a god
but never without belief in a devil
is critical i think absolutely
and um you know how how many devils
does the the new authoritarian left have
you know anything
anything that they will append phobe to
or ist to
you can find the devil there so um
if if you're being accused of being
racist you can find that white people
are the devil
if you are being accused of being sexist
you can find that men are the devil uh
that cis people are the dev that all you
know the
able-bodied people are the devil you
know all of all of these particular
ways the immutable demographics
immutable characteristics
um become the devil in this new world
order and it's
and it's quite effective because man
rage feels good
it it it and it and it and it brings
people together
even if they're not actually fighting
for anything
all right this leads to multiple things
but i i
i think the behavior of
hymenopterans um these are wasps yeah
bees and wasps are the ones
in mind in this case um have a behavior
and actually um you know but they don't
my graduate work in panama involved
dealing with the hazard of africanized
bees that there were
bees that had um been hybridized with
african strains
that went into this very aggressive
stinging behavior where
people you could die from being stung so
many times which was not
the ancestral state for our new world
version of these bees
so just i mean just notable there is
that the difference between africanized
honey bees
and non-africanized honey bees is
entirely one of behavior and a
difference in group behavior
um by by the bees right right right
transmitted
but many many many people don't
understand they you know they may think
that it's a different
it's a different venom it's like it's
it's no it's actually
when stung by one of our non-africanized
honeybees i think it's just i think it's
just apis
um typically you'll get one sting
and you know maybe a couple and you can
get away but um
africanized honey bees chase you down
they do
um and you know this is a response to
different hazards to the hive so that
you know it's not like the africanized
or the african bees are
being wasteful they just have hazards
that require a lot more stings to
dissuade them right um but the thing i
wanted to point to
is that one of the things that we have
learned in the study of these animals
is that they mark the animal that they
perceive to have been a threat to the
hive whether it was or not so if you
walk
too close to a hive and you get a sting
you are now
carrying a chemical signature and so you
now
the fact that you back away from the
hive is now not good enough because you
have been marked
as hazard to hive and therefore you
run yes you run and you hope very much
that you don't run into a thicket you
can't get through
or trip or you know and there's a famous
story
in the research circles it would now be
20 years ago at least
of a student who uh disturbed a hive in
a cave
and tripped and died was stunned to
death um but
uh but in any case the wait there was a
hive in a cave
somehow okay yeah seems strange but i
don't remember the exact story it was a
it was a
um ots student i believe but in any case
the
the fact of the
we're going to set a bar and if you
tread across it we're going to label you
with some
phobia or something like that which
makes you devil
and then you know no holds barred from
that
from that moment on that is very much
how this
seems to work now the other thing that
this makes me think though
is i must say i have
i do not resonate with the idea
of hating people very frequently
it's a very rare individual that i find
uh deserving of hate i can be very angry
i'm very angry at the behavior for
example of
these platforms and the way that they
are attempting to control the way we
think
but as for actually hating people i
reserve that for
ultra special occasions well and i think
we're going to get to you know he starts
the little excerpt that i read in the
very beginning
suggests that it's really it's a
particular kind of person
and what i'd like to do is talk about
even if you do enjoy succumbing to rage
even if you do find yourself as as
someone who has
who has done this and may be you know
flippable to a different ideology
that appears to be exactly the opposite
but it's actually the same kind of
personality
um defects really that you are revealing
how is it that you could instead become
someone who
is not as susceptible to rage who does
not find it so enjoyable
yes and in some sense i wonder i think
this goes
this is one characteristic the
propensity to hate
means that you are vulnerable to
becoming a pawn of one of these
movements and these movements are very
often driven by people who have an
agenda that isn't about you it's about
them
right um and so not being susceptible to
hate may even be like an immune
response to prevent yourself from being
capturable yes so that's
excellent not being susceptible to hate
may
provide a kind of immune response
here we have his list which is just
interesting
of um the disaffected
who are most likely to be grabbable
so apart from the discussion of can you
find yourself immune to like
apart from what you can 100 change about
your own life
these are things some of which
be very hard to escape from and so you
might have to work
harder to not succumb to a mass movement
though the disaffected are found in all
walks of life they are most frequent in
the following categories
the poor misfits outcasts
minorities adolescent youth the
ambitious
whether facing insurmountable obstacles
or unlimited opportunities
those in the grip of some vice or
obsession the impotent
in body or mind the inordinately selfish
the bored the sinners
so he then proceeds to spend many many
pages on um
a description of of many of these
which we don't have time to do for the
most part here
but i want to share a little bit
specifically about um
board i'm not sure that's what's next
though
um from that list though you know the
poor
misfits minorities etc we what we see
here if we
can read um
again i don't think that that the trump
phenomenon really is a mass movement the
way the left makes it out to be although
it does have some elements of it but if
we
if we for the moment read these as two
competing mass movements
it is in effect um pitting members of
each
of some of those groups against one
another right it's sort of you know it
is
the the left seems to have completely
forgotten about class
right which when we were growing up this
was the concern
that we understood um to be the thing
that really continues to keep people
down
and um and and trump does speak to that
whereas
um people on the left the most vocal
leaders on the left come from quite a
lot of
of money privilege which is the kind of
privilege that that speaks loudest
so um let's see
when people offer rights are ripe for a
mass movement they are usually ripe for
any effective movement
and not solely for one with a particular
doctrine or program
and furthermore since all mass movements
draw their adherence from the same types
of humanity and appeal to the same types
of mind
it follows that all mass movements are
competitive
and the gain of one in adherence is the
loss of all the others
all mass movements are interchangeable
one mass movement really transforms
itself into another
a religious movement may develop into a
social revolution or a nationalist
movement
a social revolution into militant
nationalism or religious movement
a nationalist movement into a social
revolution or a religious movement
and i would say that we saw this even
i didn't pull up any clips but in the
early days
of the post-george floyd um death
protests that were that quickly became
riots
as well we saw some you know
clearly like good faith
black lives matter people and i don't
know if they
identify as leaders or not i don't know
what kind of a hierarchical or
non-hierarchical
system they have in place but we saw
people really appealing
to rioters saying you know you you are
doing damage
to what we are trying to accomplish here
um but
what what you saw were you know a lot of
people who were disaffected who were
frustrated
seeing this outpouring of energy and yes
rage on the streets
who were coming in who even if
we allow that the germ of the black
lives matter movement
had had good people in it which
certainly it had good people in it
whether or not the original founders of
it were honest honest brokers
um it quickly became corrupted um by all
of these other people who were just
looking for a mass movement
and the argument here would be they
could have just as easily
you know they want to call themselves
communist they could have easily just
easily become fascists
um you know in any of these any of these
other ideologies that it's
the ideology isn't the driving force
it's the
it's the belonging it's the sense of
frustration it's the
frankly it's the abolition of the past
which is another thing that that he
talks about here
and in order to really dissuade one from
thinking about the past one also has to
make the idea of the present
into a living hell and so you you
you cannot imagine that today is okay or
that tomorrow was okay you're only
looking forward into
basically utopian future largely
so um i for those of you who have not
yet checked
out the podcast i did with douglas
murray definitely
worth checking out we had a great
discussion one of the things
that i raised there and that he and i
discussed
has to do with a the fact that there's a
dynamic tension between left and right
which is where the magic of our system
comes from but
i believe that there's an insidious
downside to this
to the dynamic tension yes in other
words if it is
you know if liberals are the ones with
the ambition to figure out how the
system might be made better and the
conservatives are the ones who keep the
liberals from
you know uh driving us into
terrible unintended consequences right
if that tension
is necessary to moving actually forward
but doing so with enough discipline that
you don't
fall into a utopian abyss
that the downside of it has to do with
the fact that each
each side tends to overplay its hand and
what i think is going on is
a there's because we are inherently
evolutionarily competitive beings right
and we are placed in a system that puts
us in competition with each other
right we are in competition in the
marketplace one of the go-to
moves that people who have done well or
have ended up
empowered whether or not by their own
success
one of the go-to moves for them is to
limit the access of
others to the tools that make you
powerful because of course if you've
done well
or are doing well you don't necessarily
want
everybody empowered to displace you
right so pulling up the ladder
is a go-to move at the point that you
pull up the ladder
and so you know oh my goodness education
is failing everyone it's crap
right okay so lots of people are not
being well educated which means by the
time
they reach adulthood they have dull
feeble tools right dull
feeble tools when you have them
are going to leave you susceptible to
the argument
that you should join this movement to do
away with the devil that's blocking you
from well-being
in other words the roots of
the for lack of a better term
communal communist impulse to overthrow
the structure is in the enfeebling of
people
so that they are incapable of the reason
that we are now hearing arguments
against meritocracy is that many people
have been
badly armed for meritocracy and they
know that in a meritocracy
they will not succeed hence the list
that uh
hoffer gives there of all of these
different categories of people who
resonate with these messages
so there's there's nothing in you what
you're saying
or what i'm saying or what hafer's
saying that suggests
that people don't have legitimate reason
to be frustrated
there will always be reason to be
frustrated there will always be large
numbers of people who are frustrated
and i would you know i would say as i've
said many times before here and
elsewhere
um that uh we have in fact
uniquely right now a whole generation uh
that is more widespreadly legitimately
frustrated due to this sort of perfect
storm of
um helicopter parenting which rendered
them
uh unable to to face risk and to know
what
uh what risk looks like uh the legal
drugs that have
rendered them unable to uh read or
mitigate their own moods and bodies and
ubiquitous screens that depersonalize
all interactions and you know
and the list goes on but those are sort
of the three big things that i always
come back to
that you know of of course you've got
and then you add to that
the you know the powerful who have
actually rendered an economy that's
almost impossible to enter huge loads of
debt
inability to buy real estate or get out
from under your educational debt which
didn't really educate you anyway
of course people are frustrated there
was no argument that we are making that
people should not be frustrated
but how can you turn your frustration
into something that might do good
as opposed to joining an ideology that
renders you more hopeless more helpless
more filled with rage less capable of
actually pulling yourself out of it in
the future and
and doing some good i would just add to
that
um so a ultimately if you don't want
the attack on meritocracy to topple your
functional
civilization then the answer is you have
to arm people
so that they're capable of competing in
a meritocracy so
i think one of the things that's missing
from the discussion for me is that those
of us who have succeeded in a
meritocracy
have succeeded against fewer possible
challengers than we otherwise would have
yes and that that so we are both
successful in a
context where merit matters but had an
unfair advantage
in the access to it and so the solution
to this problem ultimately involves
arming everybody to compete in a
meritocracy which
of course if you're really uh you know
ideologically
true to your values makes the market
work better
um you know yep so that is the
solution but the what we are what we are
going to see
the alternative is an attack on
meritocracy
by those who see it as a place where
they will lose and probably accurately
in most cases
and
unfortunately i don't see a solution to
that problem
there's no rapid solution because people
who are badly armed for meritocracy
cannot be
instantly armed so they are going to
engage in transfer
which is going to jeopardize everything
that works yes
okay uh hoffer continues unless a man
has the talents to make something of
himself
freedom is an irksome burden of what a
veil is freedom to choose if the self be
ineffectual
we join a mass movement to escape
individual responsibility
or in the words of the ardent young nazi
quote to be free from freedom
it was not sheer hypocrisy when the
rank-and-file nazis declared themselves
not guilty of all the enormities they
had committed
they considered themselves cheated and
maligned when made to shoulder
responsibility for obeying orders
had they not joined the nazi movement in
order to be free from responsibility
so hold on one more directly related to
that
um people whose lives are barren and
insecure seem to show a greater
willingness to obey than people who are
self-sufficient and self-confident
to the frustrated freedom from
responsibility
is more attractive than freedom from
restraint so this
this goes back to some of what we were
talking about last week with regard to
drier's book
they are eager the frustrated to barter
their independence for relief
from the burdens of willing deciding and
being responsible for inevitable failure
they willingly abdicate the directing of
their lives to those who want to plan
command and shoulder all responsibility
moreover
submission by all to a supreme leader is
an approach to their ideal
of equality in time of crisis during
floods
earthquakes epidemics depressions and
wars
separate individual effort is of no
avail and people of every condition are
ready to obey and follow a leader
to obey is then the only firm point in a
chaotic day-by-day existence
um so this this begins to bring together
some of the other
elements of the perfect storm that again
as we have said here before
uh what has been happening in portland
since the end of may
and uh what happened in most major
american cities and other major cities
throughout the world
uh in it for a short much shorter period
in the beginning of june
um would have been very unlikely to have
happened at least in the form in which
it did
absent covet 19 absent the pandemic with
which the entire world was wrestling
that that uh that that the virus
itself just and uh made it possible
for people to spill out onto the streets
because they were
more frustrated even than they ever had
been before and they were either
feeling that they needed to obey in
order to keep themselves
and their countrymen safe uh the things
like lockdowns
or they were being resistant to that uh
and
uh and feeling frustrated by uh what
felt to them
uh like authoritarian measures yeah it's
uh
it's interesting because obviously
there was not only the restriction on
one's behavior there was the looming
economic crisis which people who are
vulnerable
can detect this is going to fall very
heavily on them
and the response is exactly this being
freed from responsibility
right literally to the point of
attacking
buildings right like hammering on these
buildings
to get the federal demon to come out and
you know
confront them right it's it's uh i mean
it's a bizarre
kind of theater but you know yes
frustration is at the very root of this
because of course frustration is an
evolutionary adaptation designed to
alert you that you're in a cul-de-sac
and that you need to
somehow escape it right if you don't
have
opportunities to better yourself with
where you are then you're motivated to
seek somewhere else so
that results in all of this lashing
about for utopian states that might just
solve the problem
right uh but of course the what we the
lashing out that we see
currently on the streets of portland and
still elsewhere
is predicated on well several lies
but at least one lie that comes to mind
is the idea that they are actually
anywhere close to being able to be
self-sufficient
and you know we saw this with with jazz
chop in in seattle
these these are people who are so
confused as to the nature of what it
would mean to actually be
self-sufficient
that they um ended up getting
porta-potties sent
in by seattle um because they they
hadn't even imagined that far they're
buying food with
currency they're using their phones they
were outraged
uh when the ambulances would not enter
the space where they had violence was
occurring because
no one was willing to give the the
uh the medics uh the assurance that they
would actually be kept safe
this is this is the opposite of
self-sufficiency this is
this is children in the bodies of adults
who have deep reason to be frustrated
who don't have the tools that they
should have at the age that they're
at who are for some reason
being told by most of the leaders of
these cities and these states
that actually this is cool keep at it
guys so
that's you know this this is where we
actually need this is you know i i
hate the term nanny state precisely you
know in part because it has been used
yeah and it is it is used as a as a
as an epithet by people on the right
largely um
but you know everyone acknowledges
that actually part of what we're doing
uh with government
and with society is
keeping sufficient order uh that
when people are delusional you shut it
down
you tell them no that's wrong you're
wrong at the moment
and we're going to take you over here
and do whatever we need to do with you
to make sure that you stop putting other
people at risk
that is the role of the state yes it is
the role of the state just you know
and it's amazing how much of this
mirrors the
role of proper parents right the role of
the state is to place
limits that are clearly understandable
and to enforce them
irrespective of who violates them and
this idea
that you know oh the child is having a
tantrum
it must be very upset and i'm
sympathetic the the empathy
with the uh the
creature that is having a tantrum and
putting the entire operation
in jeopardy is
such low quality parent i mean you know
it's terrible and you know in general um
parents aren't experiencing empathy in
that in that moment they're experiencing
frustration and third through its end
and they just want to make it stop
but of course it just moves it it moves
the problem farther into the future and
in this case allowing these
society-level tantrums
is moving the problem not just farther
into the future but across a wider and
wider swath of society
shut the tantrum down it's externalizing
it onto all of us and
ultimately you can't even justify it in
terms of helping people who have a right
to be frustrated because
they will be massively harmed by the
coming apart
of the structure on which they are as
dependent as anyone else
so you know indulging their utopian
fantasies is hurting them in the future
yes
okay so um there's three more things
that i really want to get through
um before we before we stop even though
we're well beyond
our time here um
hoffer argues and this is this is this
is near and dear to my heart you will
recognize because
the idea of creativity has been one that
i have been
focused on since i was since i was a
child really
um the idea of creativity for instance
in science creativity and analysis come
together in the best science and many
people who aren't scientists imagine
that science is just about
um you know just about arraying things
and organizing them
and then you know seeing patterns emerge
something um but
there is such deep creativity in many of
the
you know more of the earlier parts of
the of the scientific method
and um it is often seemed to me that
creatives that that people who are
deeply creative which includes
many scientists and and engineers um are
are more resilient are more resistant to
uh the kinds of mass movements and
ideologies that they are
that they are advertising um and
hoffer has a couple of explanations
um for for why that might be the case
the case uh in part it speaks he says
because creativity is a cure for boredom
he says when people are bored it is
primarily with their own selves that
they are bored
the consciousness of a barren
meaningless existence is the main
fountainhead of boredom you will
remember when um
our children were very young um i was
i i was clear with them that they would
not they would not
proclaim themselves bored because that
was a failure on their part
but that is that is an insane thing to
declare yourself
um that should you say that out loud
that is it that is
demonstrative of a failure um in your
own in your own head and not to say
again that there are some people
alive who actually just do not have the
tools with which to cure their own
boredom
and of course that the advertisers and
the consumer
um the marketplace of stuff as opposed
to ideas
has made it really really easy to to
run up against the end of your own
abilities but
um certainly among children there is no
excuse for letting a child
declare themselves bored and and to walk
in and and as an adult and say i'll cure
that for you no
you let the kid you let the kid solve
their own
their own boredom um he also says
poverty at which he's speaking about
actual poverty not having enough money
poverty when coupled with creativeness
is usually free of frustration
i'm not sure i agree with this but it's
an interesting claim
poverty when coupled with creativeness
is usually free of frustration
before i go on remember this is a guy
who worked as a um
you know railroad yards and as a
stevedore no a longshoreman
um so it's this is not he is not
speaking as a man from um economic
prison can you say the sentence again
poverty
poverty when coupled with creative
creativeness
is usually free of frustration this is
true of the poor artisan skilled in his
trade and of the poor writer
artist and scientist in the full
possession of creative powers
nothing so bolsters our self-confidence
and reconciles us with ourselves
as the continuous ability to create to
see things grow and develop under our
hand
day in day out the decline of
handicrafts in modern times is perhaps
one of the causes for the rise of
frustration and the increased
susceptibility of the individual to mass
movements
so this this just dovetails beautifully
with
um you know with things that we have
said from from many avenues right that
those who actually can do something
physical um and you know we have said it
in terms
of sport isn't inherently creative
although there is a kind of creativity
in
um figuring out how to move your body
and the world and how to interface
depending on if it's a you know you
against a mountain or you against a ball
and another opponent or
you know a whole team that there is a
it's a different kind of creativity
than finding the form in the stone or
putting the words on the page or
deciphering the pattern and generating
the hypothesis
all right these are all different kinds
of creativity but what you're doing in
each case
is um is finding meaning
through creating i don't know what other
word to use something that did not exist
before
right and that the ability to watch
to watch something come into existence
that did not exist before that you did
um cannot leave you bored
you just can't be bored if you're doing
that right um
and and finally in this in just in this
section um with regard to
creativity he asks hoffer asks
whence come the fanatics
mostly from the ranks of the
non-creative men of words
the most significant division between
men of words is between those who can
find fulfillment
in creative work and those who cannot
the creative man of words no matter how
bitterly he may criticize and deride the
existing order
is actually attached to the present his
passion is to reform and not to destroy
when the mass movement remains holy in
his keeping he turns it into a mild
affair
i sure agree with that but the reforms
he initiates are of the surface and life
flows on without a sudden break
but such a development is possible only
when the anarchic action of the masses
does not come into play either because
the older advocates without a struggle
or because of man of words allies
himself with strong men of action
the moment chaos threatens to break
loose and he then provides basically a
number of
examples of what he calls non-creative
men of words including people like
hitler
who he says these are people who aspired
to be artists or writers and just
couldn't hack it
right they didn't they didn't have it in
them and
their aspirations to do something that
they were actually incapable of doing
is part of what turned them into the
despots that they were
fascinating yeah um so
i'm reminded also of one of one of my
favorite books which now i'm going to
forget the name of
um by crawford oh shopcraft as soulcraft
uh in which here we have a you know a a
deeply smart analytical panically
analytically inclined
creative man who with a phd in economics
from the university of chicago
who goes to work inside the beltway um
writing reports that 10 people will read
and that he's not sure will make any
difference at all
and gives it up for for a life that he
finds much more fulfilling
uh restoring vintage motorcycles at a at
his own shop in
virginia i think uh and it is um you
know shopcraft as soulcraft is the name
of the book it is
extraordinary and and you know i'm not
arguing
that you need to be doing something um
something physical in order to find your
creative outlet
although i think if if you have a
creative outlet
that also has some physical aspect to it
you're less likely to be fooled by it
that even those who are talented who are
truly creative
uh in purely in fields that have no
physical ramification
uh are can probably more easily be
turned
into basically propagandists can more
easily have their skill with words or
art be turned into
people who are doing the work of some
mass movement as opposed to you know if
you're if you have
if you're a craftsman uh and you know
either you've built a table that is both
functional and beautiful or you have not
it is harder to become a tool of the of
the ideology
yeah absolutely there is uh an awful lot
to having
succeeded in some place that allows you
to know what
success means rather than uh
finding that judgment through somebody
else who decides that you
are successful and leaves you open to
being manipulated exactly
okay um individual creatives aren't
sufficient though so i for
me i i i grok at a fairly deep level
and you know this is why we were
successful as professors working with
individual students
how to help individuals find their own
creative analytical productive
core self and to help make individuals
resistant to things like mass movements
but but individuals resisting isn't
really
sufficient because absent a unifying
rhetoric
values of democracy and decency are
likely to lose out to
less nuanced and less democratic
movements so i have
um
yeah maybe i want i won't read this this
longer excerpt here
um but just say um
that as i said at the beginning of this
discussion that people are
often willing to flip sides um that they
join one
and they find the the problems in it and
they become
um they're not immune to mass movements
right they're
they're actually particularly
susceptible to mass movements and
are um
perhaps just can become immune to the
particular one that they were members of
rather than um immune to mass movements
in general so
what how do we inoculate people against
that when we see people flip move
directly from one side to the other
um how can we get people to pause and
think as they're between sides for
instance as they're being rejected by
the side to which they
to which they once were tightly bound
how can they say maybe i don't belong
need to belong
to any maybe i maybe it's okay for me to
to think that ideology itself is the
problem and i might do better
by considering my positions and my hopes
for myself and my family and my
community my nation all of these nested
sets to which i belong
um from first principles rather than
from received authority
right like how how can you grab a people
who might be
recognizing that some movement to which
they are they are grabbed
um and and pull them out into a sense of
awareness um
and to that um
hoffer actually says exactly as you did
at the beginning of our conversation
that very often it's one mass movement
that comes in to displace another and
that you end up having competing mass
movements
but that can't be the only way that's
not going to be stable
that's not going to create a democracy
that's stable long term
and so just just to finish a little bit
on
leadership um he says
see with regard to leadership
the personality of the leader is
probably a crucial factor in determining
the nature and duration of a mass
movement
such rare leaders as lincoln and gandhi
not only try to curb the evil inherent
in a mass movement
but are willing to put an end to the
movement when its objective is more or
less realized
there are there of the very few in whom
power
has developed a grandeur and generosity
of the soul
and finally
there are of course rare leaders such as
again lincoln
gandhi even fdr churchill and nehru
they do not hesitate to harness man's
hungers and fears to weld a following
and make it zealous unto death in the
service of a holy cause
but unlike a hitler a stalin or even a
luther and a calvin
they are not tempted to use the slime of
frustrated souls as mortar
in the building of a new world the
self-confidence of these rare leaders is
derived from
and blended with their faith in humanity
for they know that no one can be
honorable
unless he honors mankind and that
that slime of frustrated souls which is
amazing um actually it turns out one of
his opening
um quotations in the book uh and slime
had they for mortar
i didn't know this but that comes from
genesis that comes from the old
testament i did not know that yeah
i didn't remember that either yeah so
unfortunately i think there's a problem
buried here which is that there is a
kind of
idea of how how would we solve this
problem what would we do instead
and then there's a question of what do
you do with the fact that you have
hundreds perhaps hundreds of millions if
we think
uh in a larger context than just the u.s
of people who have been hobbled by a
system that wasn't in
interested in making them capable right
right that's not a problem
you can't just start doing things right
and that problem goes away
somehow we have to deal with the fact we
have
stopped handing over the tools to be
self-sufficient that would cause people
to be less susceptible to this nonsense
and that if we started doing things
right today
it would be more than a generation
before we had gotten
past the consequences of what we've done
badly
up to this point yeah um i mean i think
this also you know this this
is a much longer conversation but um
this points to one of the real
uh criticisms of something like ubi
actually right
um that solving uh the wealth inequality
uh it wouldn't sell the wealth
inequality addressing the
vast number of people who actually
struggle to know whether or not they're
going to have enough money to
make their rent and buy food by simply
providing money
um does not provide the motivation to
create inherently there are people who
are active creatives or analysts
of sorts who are absolutely kept from
doing that work
um by the fact that they actually simply
just have to work two jobs
and cannot find the peace of mind the
space the mental space
in order to do what they desperately
want to do
but um it would it would not address um
the motivational problem
that the vast majority of people have um
who are frustrated in part because they
were not given the tools they needed and
now it seems it might be too late
yeah in fact it you can upgrade the
tools that they've got but you can't
get people you know who you
try to fix their toolkit at adulthood
the opportunity has been largely lost
and so
well i guess i'm a i'm a little
surprised to hear you say that i think i
don't know
i don't know how you do it at scale but
i feel like
um updating introducing
and updating a toolkit like an
evolutionary toolkit
is exactly what we were doing in the
classroom for
15 years yeah upgrading but it wasn't
anything like what would have been true
for
those same people if they had had
consistent
a model for a system in which the
cultivation of one's own tools results
in the growth of capacities that then
cause well-being to emerge from the
world as a result of your own
input of effort and creativity and
and skill and so you know
i i i'm very proud of what we did but
the problem is
we are dealing with people who have been
hobbled and you can
improve i mean this is true for all of
us we are all hobbled by
increasingly forces that don't care
about us and want to misinform us about
what's important and
misdirect us into you know wasting money
and time on things that we shouldn't
so anyway i'm not saying you can't make
people's
lives better what i'm saying is
a how would you you know you said you
can't do it at scale okay
so i don't know i don't know how to do
it at scale and i haven't i haven't come
up with
an answer i don't know that you can't
you will do it worse at scale than you
would do it
uh personally the number of people who
are capable of doing it personally
are very few so we can't do it for that
many and those
for whom we do it are suffering the
consequences of whatever
bad educational experiences and you know
misinformation they've gotten from
advertisers trying to frustrate them
into buying stuff and who
you know we've got damaged people and
um yes we can we can improve things
starting tomorrow
if we decided to do it but the
degree to which we are dealing with
a damaged population and that that will
require
a generation in which we are no longer
doing new damage before the problem is
actually even beginning to be solved is
i think a critical issue it's critical
but i think this is too
i think this is too hopeless i think i
mean this is often the case that you
you take a much more pessimistic view of
things than i do
um in part because i don't know how to
sleep uh with that degree of pessimism
um so does that mean that i'm engaging
in delusion perhaps
um in order
to allay the strength of mass m a mass
movement
uh that is happening on the
authoritarian left that is grabbing more
and more people
revealing to some who might be on the
fence revealing to as many as possible
of those who might be on the fence that
they could be
drawing building growing
connecting healing any number of things
that actually brings real meaning to
human existence and that that
unlike destroying yelling
raging etc is more
lasting and will make them both more
anti-fragile in general
and more resistant to the next ideology
that comes along
i agree i mean it's the obvious
direction to go the question is just how
quickly
does it change the hazard of mass
movements
and i guess we differ a little bit on
that hopefully you're right
all right so um
we will go for 15 minutes uh
but tomorrow we have our monthly private
q a
on which you can access uh by joining my
patreon
at 11 a.m pacific is when it starts it's
a two-hour
q a we've already solicited the
questions for tomorrow but
it's small enough that we are often able
to watch the chat as it happens and
sometimes engage with
with that in real time uh starting
next weekend i guess are the
conversations that you have
on your on your patreon wait that
suggests we're almost done with october
yes it does oh my god
um and of course you can join um the
discord server
as as well um
but if you want to ask a question in the
next hour where we will be
we will be doing just that pose your
super chat question either
right now um or at the top of the next
hour
and we will get through as many of them
as we can
yep do check out the new podcast
with douglas murray that i put out a
couple days ago
he was here reporting from portland on
what he sees and i think
actually it is essential that those of
you who
are outside of portland and don't really
know what's been going on here
hearing somebody come from great britain
and look in on portland and report on
what he's seeing is
really eye-opening yeah highly recommend
it i have not listened to your
conversation with him yet
but we had dinner with him and his
partner the night before you did your
podcast
and um yeah seeing
you know we don't share politics but we
are friends
and he is he's just such an
extraordinarily gracious and
brilliant man and um seeing someone
not from here come in and observe
and see what's going on and hearing his
incisive insightful takes is
extraordinary yeah i'm sure your
conversation was amazing
yes he's uh he's a a great guy and
um it's wonderful to have him as a
friend and
and wonderful that we aren't in the same
political place because the discussions
are definitely
highly productive yeah alright we'll see
you in 15 minutes
be well
you